[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen guten Abend wünsche ich
Ihnen und den Sport den hat Norbert
Lehmann für Sie einen schönen guten
Abend von mir unsere großen Themen
wie viel Geld für Familien die Kinder
Grundsicherung soll kommen beim
Elterngeld gibt es Streit
schlechte Stimmung in der deutschen
Wirtschaft die Chemiebranche schwächelt
und die Exporte gehen überraschend
zurück
Countdown für die Frauenfußball-WM das
Training des DFB-Teams geht in
Herzogenaurach in die Endphase
[Musik]
nach langem Ringen soll die
Kindergrundsicherung jetzt im August
beschlossen werden vor allem für die
Grünen ist sie ein Herzensprojekt FDP
Finanzminister Lindner will dafür aber
erstmal weniger Geld bereitstellen als
gefordert morgen soll der Haushalt für
2024 im Kabinett beschlossen werden aber
jetzt ist noch eine weitere
Auseinandersetzung dazu gekommen und
zwar über das Elterngeld mehr von Andrea
Maurer
es ist der nächste Streit zwischen dem
fdp-finanzminister und der Grünen
Familienministerin sie habe von
Christian Lindner den Auftrag bekommen
beim Elterngeld zu kürzen und habe sich
entschieden die Einkommensgrenze zu
senken sagt Lisa Paus ja die Grenze der
Einkommen für diejenigen die Elterngeld
beziehen können wird abgesenkt auf
150.000 Euro zu versteuern des
Jahreseinkommen das wird vermutlich
60.000 Familientreffen das ist kein
Landstück für Gleichstellung in diesem
Land aber unter den schlechten
Rahmenbedingungen habe ich mir für diese
Variante entschieden bislang bekommen
Paare mit einem Jahreseinkommen von bis
zu 300.000 Euro nach der Geburt eines
Kindes Elterngeld wenn sie im Job
pausieren die Einkommensgrenze für
Alleinerziehende liegt bei 250.000 €
ausgezahlt werden bis zu 1.800 € im
Monat einer Senkung der Einkommensgrenze
auf 150.000 € würde auch doppelt
verdienende Paare der Mittelschicht
treffen die FDP distanziert sich von
denen falsch gerade vor dem Hintergrund
des Ziels der Gleichstellung von Mann
und Frauen der Familie ich halte es für
falsch dass wir an dieser Stelle genau
diese Mittel jetzt kürzen auf Twitter
veröffentlicht die Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin im Familienministerium
die Aufforderung aus dem FDP-geführten
Finanzministerium 500 Millionen Euro
durch eine Ausgaben reduzierende Reform
des Elterngeldes einzusparen die Union
nennt die Koalitionspläne ein fatales
Signal für Familien in Deutschland
dieser Weg den die Koalition jetzt geht
schränkt die Möglichkeiten für viele
Familien in Deutschland vor allen Dingen
solche die in großen Städten leben und
dort hohe Lebenshaltungskosten haben
spürbar ein Lindners Haushaltsentwurf
soll morgen durchs Kabinett bisher war
das hauptstreit-thema die
Kindergrundsicherung der neue Streit ums
Elterngeld liegt neue Gräben offen
fehlende Fachkräfte hohe Energie-
die Exporte sind im Mai um 0,1 Prozent
zum Format auf 130,5 Milliarden Euro
gesunken so sind die Geschäfte mit der
EU geschrumpft wie auch mit den USA die
Gründe nach wie vor hohe Inflationsraten
und das gestiegene Zinsniveau mehr von
Patricia wieder Meier
deutsche Qualität sie scheint
international nicht mehr so gefragt zu
sein wie früher die Exporte sinken im
Mai waren es 0,7% weniger als im Mai vor
einem Jahr die übliche frühjahrserholung
sei ausgeblieben so die deutsche
Industrie und Handelskammer weltweit
sind vielfältige Krisen zu spüren und
das ist die corona-krise mit
Lieferengpässen mit Preissteigerungen
die für Unternehmen Kostensteigerung
bedeutet haben und wir für die Menschen
in vielen Plätzen auf der Welt Inflation
Kaufkraftverlust der Industrie machen
vor allem die hohen Energiepreise zu
schaffen im letzten Jahr hatte BASF zum
Beispiel 3,2 Milliarden Euro mehr kosten
nur für Energie die Folge
2600 Stellen werden gestrichen
Produktionsverfahren verlagert mit
Subventionen einem industriestrompreis
will die Regierung helfen experten
halten das für den falschen Weg ich
würde mehr davon halten zu versuchen die
allgemein Rahmenbedingungen für
Unternehmen zu verbessern also
steuerlich Entlastungen weniger
Bürokratie
Regulierung überprüfen
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen das
ist besser als auf einen
industriestrompreis zu setzen das sieht
der Wirtschaftsminister ganz anders RB
die Industrie im Land halten die
Transformation finanzieren um
Deutschland unabhängiger auch bei
Rohstoffen zu machen da geht es nicht
nur um ökonomische Fragen sondern auch
um die Frage ob wir jedenfalls die
Kenntnisse der Produktion und gewisse
Anteile der Produktion hier haben und
ich finde die Antwort kann ja nur ja
sein das muss es uns wert sein das haben
wir doch die letzten Jahre politisch
gepennt Habeck waren vor Abhängigkeiten
China habe bereits Exportbeschränkungen
eingeführt für wichtige Metalle und
Rohstoffe möglichst unabhängig werden
und dabei die Wirtschaft stärken das sei
das Ziel
reichere Bundesländer Zahlen für weniger
Wirtschaft starke damit vergleichbare
Lebensverhältnisse in ganz Deutschland
herrschen gegen diesen
Länderfinanzausgleich will Bayern nun
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht klagen
das hat das Kabinett in München heute
beschlossen das Ausgleichssystem sei
ungerecht Bayern ist seit Jahren größter
Einzahler die Opposition nannte das
Vorhaben der Regierung aus CSU und
Freien Wählern
das ist noch nie in der Geschichte des
Bundestages vorgekommen aller
Voraussicht nach werden die
Regierungsfraktionen von SPD grün und
FDP einen Antrag der Opposition auf
einen Untersuchungsausschuss ablehnen
ein urausschuss ist eines der
wichtigsten Rechte der Opposition und
ihr schärfste Schwert
cdu/csu wollten es nutzen um den
Finanzskandal um die Hamburger
warburgbank zu beleuchten es geht dabei
um die Rolle des früheren Hamburger
Bürgermeisters und heutigen Kanzlers
Olaf Scholz lass uns
gerade mal 30 Minuten tagte der
Geschäftsordnungsausschuss des
Bundestags da war der erwartete Streit
bereits eskaliert wer hier für mich
heute gegen die Verfassung verstoßen hat
das ist die Koalition in einer
eklatanten Art und Weise in 70-jähriger
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und das wird morgen auch im
Parlament aufzuarbeiten sein ähnlich wie
schon in Hamburg will die Union einen
Untersuchungsausschuss der die Rolle des
heutigen Kanzlers und früheren Hamburger
Bürgermeister Scholz im Skandal um die
Warburg Bank beleuchtet das sei
verfassungswidrig sagen die
Regierungsparteien denn der
Untersuchungsausschuss des Bundestags
mit überwiegend des Verwaltungshandeln
Hamburgs untersuchen
von den 19 Fragen die die Union
formuliert hat war die Mehrzahl ziemlich
klar nicht verfassungsgemäß und deswegen
mussten wir diesen Antrag in seiner
Gänze ablehnen wir konnten auch nicht
teilweise annehmen weil ein teilweise
veränderter Antrag ein anderer Antrag
ist Empörung bei der Union Fraktionschef
März kündigt an vors Verfassungsgericht
zu ziehen
die Koalition hat offensichtlich die
Entscheidung getroffen auf biegen und
brechen die mehrheitsrechte gegen die
Minderheitsrechte im Deutschen Bundestag
durchzusetzen niemand kann einen von
eben einen Organ was in der Verfassung
verankert ist nämlich vom Deutschen
Bundestag verlangen verfassungswidrige
Anträge zuzustimmen was darf der
Bundestag und was nicht eine sehr
grundsätzliche Frage die das
Verfassungsgericht beantworten muss
im Krieg gegen die Ukraine hat Russland
einmal mehr zivile Ziele weit hinter der
Front angegriffen in der Region Harke
schlug eine Granata ein durch die
Explosion wurden in einem Wohngebiet der
Stadt perwomajski 31 Menschen verletzt
neun davon sein Kinder teilte der
Gouverneur der Region mit mehrere Autos
auf einem zentralen Parkplatz gerieten
in Brand umliegende Mehrfamilienhäuser
wurden beschädigt die getroffene Stadt
liegt über 100 km von der aktuellen
Frontlinie entfernt
der russische Überfall auf die Ukraine
hatte dafür gesorgt dass
nato-generalsekretärin Stoltenberg seine
Amtszeit vergangenes Jahr verlängert
hatte nun wurde bekannt gegeben der
Norweger bleibt noch ein weiteres Jahr
auf dem Spitzenposten der Grund die 31
Mitgliedstaaten des Militärbündnisses
konnten sich nicht auf einen Nachfolger
verständigen
Stoltenberg hatte zuletzt wiederholt
gesagt dass er eigentlich nicht mehr
antreten will twitterte heute aber er
fühlte sich geehrt
in Frankreich hat sich die Lage nach den
gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen am
Wochenende etwas beruhigt in der
vergangenen Nacht kam es noch vereinzelt
zu Unruhen die Polizei nahm rund 70
Personen fest mehr als 240 Bürgermeister
und BürgermeisterInnen aus den Städten
in denen die Ausschreitungen besonders
heftig waren kam heute in elise-palast
der Höhepunkt der krawalliser
überschritten sagte Präsident macron in
den letzten Tagen wurden tausende Autos
sind Brand gesetzt und mehr als 1.100
Gebäude beschädigt
und was ich gerade in Frankreich
abspielt wirft auch ein Schlaglicht auf
die Lebensverhältnisse in
benachteiligten Vierteln eine wichtige
Arbeit leisten dort Vereine die
Jugendarbeit machen und in denen sich
die Eltern organisieren über ein
Beispiel aus Notar berichtet
die Wut über den Tod von nael haben sie
auf die Mauern geschrieben einige der
Jugendlichen hier kannten ihn in UI
einer Hochhaussiedlung nördlich von
montere trifft sich eine Gruppe von
Müttern sie machen sich Sorgen um ihre
Kinder
die Frau nimmt selbst wenn du sie gut
erziehst und sie sich zu Hause Benehmen
weißt du nicht was sie draußen machen
wenn sie etwas organisieren machen sie
das über die soziale Netzwerke und die
Eltern kriegen nichts mit das ist hier
im Viertel keine schlimmen krawale gab
lege auch an ihrem Verein erklärt Hadi
der Gründer über die Jahre haben sie
Vertrauen aufgebaut zu den Familien und
den Jugendlichen
und deshalb hören Sie uns jetzt auch zu
es ist wichtig die Verbindung im Alltag
aufrecht zu halten denn wenn man erst
dann mit ihnen redet wenn es sich wieder
entzündet kommt das schlechter deswegen
ebenso wie macronsforderung Eltern der
Randalierer finanziell zu bestrafen das
löse kein einziges Problem in Frankreich
sozialbausiedlungen wachsen viele
Jugendliche mit dem Gefühl auf
ausgeschlossen zu sein das rechtfertigt
nicht die Gewalt erklärt aber den Frust
der Verein in UI versucht ihm zu
begegnen mit Freizeitangeboten
man soll die Kinder nicht einsperren
sondern sie in den Gemeinden zu gut es
geht begleiten das versucht doch super
sie hat sechs Kinder ihr ältester Sohnes
wenn ich in den Nachrichten sehe dass
die Jugendlichen wieder loslegen dann
spreche ich meinen Sohn darauf an
versuche ihn zurückzuhalten damit er da
nicht mitmacht
ich will keine Scherereien das ist schon
heftig alles das was passiert ist ist
Unrecht ich verstehe dass sie zerstören
wollen aber es gibt auch andere Wege
zu aber und die anderen Mütter bleiben
aufmerksam auch wenn es dieser Tage in
ihrem Viertel friedlich ist
interessante Zahlen jetzt zur Bildung in
Deutschland immer mehr Schülerinnen und
Schüler machen Abitur meldet das
Statistische Bundesamt
2021 hat gut ein Drittel von ihnen die
Schulzeit so abgeschlossen vor 20 Jahren
waren es noch deutlich weniger die
meisten in der neuen Statistik machten
einen Realschulabschluss und gut sechs
Prozent der jungen Menschen starteten
ganz ohne Abschluss ins Berufsleben das
ist ein leichter Anstieg gegenüber 2020
Lebensmittel speziell für Kinder
enthalten häufig mehr Zucker Fett oder
Salz als vergleichbare Fertigprodukte
für Erwachsene das ist das Ergebnis
einer Auswertung die vom
Bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium
vorgestellt wurde Hintergrund der
Untersuchung ist die freiwillige
Selbstverpflichtung der Industrie diese
krank und dick machenden Zutaten nach
und nach zu reduzieren doch statt auf
weniger setzte die Branche bei einigen
Produkten sogar auf mehr ungesunde
Inhaltsstoffe instrums
das ist für mich die Verlockungen im
Supermarkt für die Kleinen sind groß
doch noch immer enthalten oftmals gerade
die Produkte die sich an Kinder richten
zu viel an zuckerfetten und Salz
ernährungsminister Özdemir legt neue
Zahlen vor und demonstriert wie viel
Zucker in einem Glas Erfrischungsgetränk
für Kinder stecken kann niemand sagt das
soll verboten werden niemand sagt es
darf man nicht trinken sondern der
Appell ist an die Industrie bitte
reduzieren Sie den Anteil den Zucker
daran so enthalten etwa Frühstücks
Cerealien für Kinder mit dem Schnitt 17
Gramm pro 100 Gramm mehr Zucker als der
Durchschnitt aller Cerealien mit 14,7
Gramm Zucker Fett Salz schmecken doch
Übergewicht und krank machende
Fettleibigkeit die Folgen wir haben in
etwa 15% der Kinder und Jugendliche in
unserem Land die übergewichtig sind und
fast sechs Prozent adipöse Kinder und
Jugendliche
die Unternehmen entgegnen sie seien auf
einem guten Weg hin zu gesünderen
Lebensmitteln doch Rezepturen seien
nicht einfach zu verändern und dann gebe
es ja auch noch den Verbraucher die
Vergangenheit zeigt dass der Verbraucher
nur bis zu einem bestimmten Grad bereit
ist geschmackliche Veränderung eines
Produktes zu akzeptieren und dann
passiert folgendes dann wird dieses
Produkt nicht mehr gekauft es steht wie
Blei im Regal Minister Özdemir bleibt
derweil nur an die Unternehmen zu
appellieren und seine Pläne eines
Werbeverbots für ungesunde
Kinderlebensmittel durchzusetzen
das Bundesverfassungsgericht verhandelt
seit heute über die NPD die sich jetzt
die Heimat nennt erstmals prüft das
höchste Gericht ob die rechtsextrem von
der staatlichen Parteienfinanzierung
ausgeschlossen werden können
und es Tag Bundesrat und Bundesregierung
haben das 2019 beantragt zwei
Verbotsverfahren gegen die Partei waren
bis dahin gescheitert politisch spielen
die Rechtsextremen derzeit keine Rolle
bei der Bundestagswahl 2021 kam die
Partei auf 0,1 Prozent Birgit Franke und
Christoph Schneider
die Stühle der Antragsgegnerin blieben
bei der Verhandlung leer die der NPD die
sich seit Anfang Juni in die Heimat
umbenannt hat dafür sind die drei
Antragsteller Bundesrat Bundestag und
Bundesregierung umso zahlreicher
erschienen wollen der Heimat den
staatlichen Geldhahn zudrehen
es ist umfassend zusammengetragen worden
dass die NPD eine verfassungsfeindliche
Partei ist die auch eine
staatszersetzende Demokratie zersetzende
Wirkung entfaltet nachdem zwei Versuche
scheiterten die Heimat wegen erwiesener
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit verbieten zu
lassen wurde 2017 unter der großen
Koalition mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit das
grundgesetzer weitert danach können
Parteien die die freiheitliche
demokratische Grundordnung
beeinträchtigen oder beseitigen wollen
die staatlichen Mittel entzogen werden
davon sind die Antragsteller im Fall der
NPD überzeugt aus meiner Sicht ist es
wichtig dass dieses Verfahren geführt
wird denn die größte Gefahr in
Deutschland geht für die demokratische
Grundordnung nun mal vom
Rechtsextremismus aus und deswegen ist
es ein wichtiges Verfahren auch über die
Fragen der Finanzierung zu reden ohne
die Heimat schriftlich teilt die Partei
auf ihrer Homepage mit die Beratung wird
ohne Vertreter der heimatreuen Partei
stattfinden weil sich der Bundesvorstand
weigert sich zum Statisten einer
justizsimulation machen zu lassen
der Zweite Senat des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts ist mit
Sachverständigen tief eingestiegen und
will prüfen
welche Entwicklung die
Antragsgegnerin seit Januar 2017
genommen hat insbesondere ob Sie nach
wie vor als verfassungsfeindlich
einzustufen ist das mit Spannung
erwartete Urteil wird noch in diesem
Jahr erwartet
die Tat ging vielen Menschen in
Deutschland nahe in Eller Kirchberg
greift ein Mann unvermittelt zwei
Schülerinnen mit einem Messer an eines
der Mädchen stirbt ein gutes halbes Jahr
ist das jetzt her nun wurde der Täter
vom Landgericht Ulm wegen Mordes und
versuchten Mordes mit gefährlicher
Körperverletzung verurteilt ein Bericht
von Eva Schiller
es ist das Ende eines aufwühlenden
Prozesses am Ulmer Landgericht verkündet
der Richter sein Urteil lebenslang mit
besonderer Schwere der Schuld für den
geflüchteten aus Eritrea es war das
maximale was das Gericht aussprechen
konnte und das hat auch gemacht und
deswegen sind wir zufrieden dezember
2022 auf dem Weg zur Schule gehen die
14-Jährige ätsche und ihre Freundin an
der Flüchtlingsunterkunft vorbei
plötzlich läuft ein Mann auf sie zu
grüßt kurz und sticht dann völlig
unvermittelt auf die Mädchen ein ECE
stirbt ihre Freundin wird schwer
verletzt waren reine Zufallsopfer man
kann tatsächlich sagen die beiden
Mädchen waren an diesem Tag zu falschen
Zeit im falschen Ort er habe sich an den
Mitarbeitern im Landratsamt rächen
wollen sagte 27-Jährige später wegen der
Schwere der Schuld kann er nicht
vorzeitig nach 15 Jahren entlassen
werden für Illerkirchberg setzt dieses
Urteil trotzdem keinen Schlusspunkt der
Ruf nach
Aufarbeitung ist da und wie man hier vor
Ort dann mit solchen geflüchteten umgeht
und damit die Angst weg ist muss man
eben wieder Vertrauen schaffen
sich gewünscht dass die
Flüchtlingsunterkunft abgerissen wird
das ist passiert nicht Hass und Hetze
sollen wachsen sondern eine Wiese für
alle Kinder des Ortes
in vielen Regionen der Welt ist das
Wetterphänomen El Niño gefürchtet nun
ist es nach mehreren Jahren wieder da
die weltwetterorganisation warnt in der
zweiten Jahreshälfte vor
temperaturrekorden und extremen
Wetterereignissen besonders etwa in
Südostasien Australien und Mittelamerika
die Folgen der Klimakrise dürften sich
zusätzlich verschärfen El nino ist ein
natürliches Wetterphänomen im tropischen
Pazifik bei dem sich Wasser und
Luftströmungen verändern
können wir zum Sport zum deutschen
Fußballnationalteam der Frauen Norbert
in 16 Tagen startet er die WM ja und
jetzt bereitet sich das Team vom
Bundestrainerin Martina Forst
Tecklenburg in Herzogenaurach vor mit 29
Spielerinnen mit dem endgültigen 23er
Kader geht es dann am Montag nach
Australien wobei vielleicht werden es
auch ein zwei Spielerinnen mehr sein
sie präsentieren ein wirgefühl und ihren
Sieges Willen alle 29 Spielerinnen der
WM Vorbereitung sind fokussiert
trainieren sogar die Zeitumstellung den
ab dem 24 Juli soll alles passen in Down
Under das Testspiel gegen Vietnam zeigte
trotz 2:1 noch viele Problemstellen
daran wird in Herzogenaurach gearbeitet
alle Spielerinnen präsentieren sich
super insofern ist es für uns sehr sehr
schwierig dann auch zu selektieren dann
werden sie es dann am Samstag erfahren
wer dabei ist und wenn nicht nach dem
Testspiel gegen Sambia gibt die
Bundestrainerin ihren WM-Kader bekannt
wohl mehr als 23 Spielerinnen denn die
weiter Anreise würde nach Nominierungen
erschweren
übrigens ein WM-Gewinn der Frauen würde
den DFB knapp vier Millionen Euro
Einnahmen bringen Geld dass er gut
gebrauchen könnte angesichts akuter
Finanzprobleme etwa wegen des
überteuerten neuen DFB Campus der
Verband hat deshalb heute Einsparungen
Höhe von 15 Millionen Euro angekündigt
zur vierten Etappe der Tour de France da
kamen heute noch mal die Sprinter zum
Zug auf den knapp 142 km von Sachsen
und auch wieder auf dem Podest viel
Bauhaus
bereits 20 Kilometer vor dem Ziel ist
viel Bauhaus von seinem Team in Position
gebracht eine weitere Etappe für den
Sprinter aus Bocholt auf dem
motorrennkurs von Nogaro ist es mit dem
Bummel Tempo schlagartig vorbei ein
weiterer Massensprint deutet sich an
einer mit Haken und Ösen mit Favorit
Fabio Jacobsen stürzt und Bauhaus kommt
erst spät von hinten zu spät um in den
Sport um den Sieg zwischen Jasper
Philipsen und Keller Bio in einzugreifen
die ersten drei von gestern wieder vorn
leicht verändert diesmal Philips sind
vor jungen Dritter Bauhaus ich wusste
oder ich weiß dass ich jetzt nicht der
Topf Favorit bin auf dem Weg aber
denke ich habe jetzt auch bewiesen dass
ich dass ich zu dem besten gehöre der
bisher schnellste Mann dieser Tour heißt
Jasper Philipsen doch viel Bauhaus kommt
nicht weit dahinter
und morgen geht's in die Pyrenäen die
erste echte Kraftprobe für die Favoriten
danke schön
das Wetter bringt uns morgen Sturm und
Gewitter genau das gleich von Christa
Abend das heute journal läuft um 21:45
Uhr mit Christian sie was tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend vor der Hitze am Wochenende
erreicht uns jetzt erst einmal ein
richtiges Sturmtief das ist ungewöhnlich
für die Jahreszeit und sieht morgen über
den Nordwesten die Deutsche Bucht bis
nach Skandinavien zwei Dinge müssen wir
im Auge behalten zum einen das
hauptsturmfeld südlich des Tiefs und zu
anderen die Gewitter vor und an der
Kaltfront zunächst zum Wind der gesamte
Nordwesten bekommt es morgen mindestens
mit stürmischen Böden bis Sturmböen um
80 km pro Stunde zu tun das ganze geht
aber bis hin zu 130 km/h also Orkanböen
nach aktuellem Stand sind die am
wahrscheinlichsten an der Nordseeküste
ganz genau wissen wir das aber erst
morgen wie sieht es mit der Kaltfront
aus die erreicht schon in der zweiten
Nachthälfte den Westen mit
schauerartigen Regen und eingelagerten
Gewittern die ziehen zwar schnell haben
aber punktuell Starkregen und Sturmböen
dabei morgen breitet sich das Ganze
schnell in den Osten aus ist nachmittags
hier auch schon durchgezogen am längsten
blitzt und donnert ist noch im Südosten
außerdem gibt's im Tagesverlauf noch den
länger anhaltenden Regen in der Nähe des
Tiefs im Nordwesten in der Mitte lockert
es aber auch schnell wieder auf die
Temperaturen dazu liegen zwischen 17 und
27 Grad ab Donnerstag ist es mit dem
Sturm vorbei zum Wochenende wird es dann
heiß wie lange diese Hitze allerdings
bleibt ist noch ungewiss